she's up on the information so brad pitt
uh-huh my boyfriend your boyfriend is
dating like a 26 year old supermodel who
was married to a european restauranteur
she's gorgeous he's 90.
who brad no the
the restaurant
and she was seeing brad
brad was her side piece
brad was a side [ __ ] they went to the
south of france together
came back splitsville now him and i are
totes serious
yeah yeah
she must be beautiful i mean
beautiful yes she's gorgeous i'm just
hating on her pillow lips right
they're not natural i can't imagine and
if they are i want the dna from where
she i mean she's gorgeous look at her
are you guys she's pretty gorgeous yeah
she's like absolutely
steely posturepedic mouth yeah yeah yeah
you could take a nap on those things
it's a beautiful face yeah when did but
when did when did that become something
i never have it growing up though i
never when i saw
that
i think people talk like that with
lipsticks yes you must but i never saw a
woman like this i never go oh that's
hard
i don't know but have you you do make
fun of people without lips that is true
and your girl has a beautiful mouth
you have a beautiful man thank you her
mouth is one very big
great mouth
yeah
i don't like i don't like white chicks
when they're they're not there this hi
i'm commander they're like hi i'm i'm
yeah i don't like that i feel like
that's going to come back though i
guarantee you we're going to pendulum
will eventually swing over to the thin
lip side oh god here is hoping imagine
just like extracting the [ __ ]
fat out of my lips you know what i'm
gonna buy the kardashians lips
when they reverses and they take them
off yeah i'll just hold one of them like
this yes yeah i mean and i got i got
kim's blower lip but you know they don't
look like a [ __ ] baby whale they
don't stay they don't stay their fillers
they're going to dissolve over time oh
no yeah it's like hyaluronic acid acid
and your body like eats it eats it it
was just a joke and you guys
well guys got science there's you guys
got science we got science
[ __ ] whale joke and then you got
sciencey with it too much brain between
what the [ __ ] is going on around here
well no because of the lips when they
detach from the you know i
is it bullying
female bullying it's because of chovid
it's because of covid it's because of
the pandemic we're just used to being
inside there's no more shows there's no
more live shows now everything has to be
explained yeah you can't just enjoy [ __ ]
yeah yeah
are you working a lot though or no i
actually have i've been fortunate i have
worked a couple times doing like covert
proof things like i booked a netflix
thing that was awesome and fun what was
it uh it's a reality-based show was it
no title right now oh no uh kind of
around tattoos and people struggle oh
yeah yeah cool a lot of fun but i had to
leave sex my mom got super sick so i'd
like
break the covet production and fly from
la to upstate new york to be with my mom